[Music]
this video is about the music of Ludwig
van Beethoven one of the greatest
composers of all time first I'm going to
study and analyze his piano sonatas and
with that information I'm going to
attempt to create my own piano sonata in
the style of Beethoven and hopefully in
this process we can all learn about how
Beethoven structured his music some of
his compositional elements and just
appreciate his genius
there are three things in particular
that I want to focus on first the Sonata
Allegro form motivic development and
rhetoric so Sonata Allegro form to
explain this extremely simply let's
imagine three sections in the first
section let's imagine two shapes of two
different colors let's say a red
triangle and a blue circle in the second
section these two shapes and these two
colors interact with each other in
different ways they get transformed they
get expanded upon broken up and they
move in many different directions in the
third section order is restored and
again we find two shapes but instead of
having two different colors we'll have
both
shapes in red now what's interesting is
that if you look very carefully the
shapes and colors that you find in the
third section are slightly different
from that of the first section and that
is because of what they went through in
the second section or the development
now motivic development ties into this
form here because this is the way that
cells or different fragments of melody
or rhythm could be expanded upon
transformed and developed now I also
mentioned rhetoric because a lot of
beethoven's phrases are rather speech
like the way that they interact with
each other how they begin and how they
and how they're strung together they
really follow a lot of the patterns and
a lot of the techniques in rhetoric so
the definition of rhetoric the art of
effective or persuasive speaking or
writing especially the use of figures of
speech and other compositional
techniques kind of like how there are
literary devices that help make speech
or text a lot more effective in terms of
communication there are compositional
devices that do the same as well just in
musical terms so in getting to the
arrangement I know that I'm going to be
using the Sonata Allegro form I'll have
two themes and I'll of course reference
the happy birthday melody I think the
first order of business is to come up
with the two themes and for that I'm
going to start off with happy birthday
in the key of D minor
from that I'm going to focus on just the
first two pitches because when you pay
attention to what Beethoven does for
example in his fifth symphony that we
all know the rest of the entire symphony
movement can always be traced back to
those opening pitches which is only two
pitches of course the repeated pitch and
then a pitch a third below but really
everything stems from that so in similar
fashion I'm choosing the first two
pitches from happy birthday in D minor
and instead of having a single line I
think it'll be more interesting in
thirds this is what you call a motive or
a motif basically core material from
which a bunch of other phrases other
sections get built from so in order to
build from somewhere it's great to start
with something very small and basic like
two pitches I purposely made the
direction of these gestures opposite
from one another it's almost like a
question and an answer in a very micro
form and then there is a longer gesture
so it's all three components make up a
short short long phrase now on to the
second theme traditionally the key of
the second theme is related somehow to
that of the first for example if we're
in a major key the second theme will
most likely be in the dominant key which
is the five so C major to say G major in
minor keys most often you'll find the
second theme in the relative major so
major three or also five so with that in
mind my second theme will be in F major
the relative major key to D minor and
I'm going to use this part or happy
birthday dear so and so from the
original happy birthday melody as a
melodic material and I want it to be in
contrast to the first theme
now that I have the main pillars for my
Sonata I need to figure out ways to
connect the dots and fill in the blanks
so here I have both volumes of the
Beethoven sonatas volume 1 volume 2 this
happened when I got really frustrated
you know I'm just kidding I'm not sure
why this so what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to record as many of these
phrases as I can possibly manage right
now and from that I'm going to compile a
list of compositional characteristics
that I see of Beethoven's music
especially in his piano sonatas repeated
chords
more courts wide broken chords
[Music]
Unison's or two lines spaced an octave
apart playing the same exact line hand
crossings specifically this type
broken octaves staggered Octus contrast
a lot of contrast diminished chords
which you find everywhere both in chord
form and arpeggiated form
long trills
[Music]
imitative layers
themes with horn calls and horns in
general
[Music]
enter lines extremely warm and beautiful
melodies
[Music]
a lot of times you'll find scales and
arpeggios just in their straight form
for an entire phrase either as a single
note or in octaves and a lot of times I
think that's kind of hard to pull off
but Beethoven makes it sound pretty
emphatic and epic this is probably the
most intense descending minor scale in
all of piano repertoire
[Music]
the clam Ettore moments which are also
accompanied by rests and bouts of
silence
[Music]
call-and-response
repeated peddle points
outer petal lines so this is sort of the
opposite of a petal point you'll find a
note or an octave surrounding certain
chords that are moving that stays the
same
[Music]
turns
sequences repeated pairs hard
oh okay I think that's enough for today
now I'm focusing a lot on these two
pitches a and b-flat and specifically
the semitone relationship another thing
I want to mention is the way that I
played it because that's quite important
say that I played it with a lot more
pedal with a gentler fuzzier type of
sound it might sound like this
and now again the way that I played it
[Music]
[Applause]
so as you can hear there is a huge
difference even though I'm playing the
exact same pitches with the exact same
rhythm and in this particular case I
think a term that comes in handy is non
legato which is kind of halfway between
something that is staccato short and dry
and something that is legato long fluid
connected of course there are many other
factors and many other things that are
involved in the way you play that will
make your playing sound more or less
Beethoven but I think that depends on
the piece now after a number of drafts
and revisions here is happy birthday in
the style of Ludwig van Beethoven in
honor of his 250th celebration
you
[Music]
and making additional footage from this
project available to my patrons on
patreon such as a more in-depth analysis
of a Beethoven piano sonata more on how
I came up with my own arrangement and
extended versions of some of the
examples shown in the video as always
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you in the next video I'm not really
sure if this is possible why do I feel
stressed I feel stressed okay